einst reichere todesstreifen zwischen
ost und westdeutschland
heute ist es eines der größten deutschen
naturschutzgebiete der nationalpark harz
entstanden vor 30 jahren genauso lang
kümmert sich biologe gunter karste darum
dass hier wieder zusammenwächst was
zusammengehört
das besondere am nationalpark ist
tatsächlich die tatsache dass man auf
24.700 30 hektar bereit ist der natur
ihren eigenen spielraum zu lassen
dass man also darauf verzichtet prinzip
die fläche zu nutzen also in richtung
klassischer holzwirtschaft und dass man
also tatsächlich der natur die chance
gibt zu zeigen wozu sie in der lage ist
[Musik]
damals mussten die frauen und männer des
nationalparks bei null anfangen wie hier
am ehemaligen todesstreifen 1989
patrouillierten hier ddr grenzschützer
eine hunderte meter breite schneise
sollte jede flucht aus der ddr
verhindern
die grenzanlagen ein fast
unüberwindliches bollwerk aus
stacheldraht und beton
[Musik]
drei jahrzehnte später hat die natur
hier ganze arbeit geleistet
die bürger hat hier also tatsächlich das
rennen gemacht dieser streifen wurde mit
herbiziden pestiziden behandelt und
trier war eigentlich kein leben möglich
und man sieht jetzt hier
hier ist in den letzten 30 jahren
tatsächlich so viel passiert doch nicht
nur pflanzen auch tiere erobern sich im
harz ihrer angestammten lebensräume
zurück mit solchen versteckten kameras
wird auch der neue wilde bewohner des
nationalparks dokumentiert der luchs vor
gut 200 jahren war die raubkatze
ausgestorben jetzt sind hier weit mehr
als 100 exemplare wieder heimisch der
letzten alba hat fahren der vom menschen
ausgerottet wurde und der sich verdient
hat also hier auch wieder im harz
unterwegs zu sein und vor dem
hintergrund war das also das große
experiment was der nationalpark 1994 95
gestartet hat diesen luchs wieder
einzubürgern erfolgsgeschichten unter
denen harte arbeit steckt tausende
stunden war der biologe in den wäldern
unterwegs zehntausende notizen wie sich
die natur die grenzregion zurückerobert
[Applaus]
und doch steht die größte
herausforderung für die frauen und
männer des nationalparks noch bevor tote
bäume so weit das auge reicht früher
waren hier riesige fichten kulturen
trockenheit und steigende temperaturen
haben die bäume geschwächt den rest
besorgte der borkenkäfer immer häufiger
muss karsten deshalb bei seinen touren
aufklärungsarbeit leisten es richtig
traurig wenn man hier hoch geht aber man
muss auch wissen kurse wenden sie hier
in diese fläche schauen da wo die
fichten also beispielsweise sich schon
vor längerer zeit verabschiedet haben da
entsteht neues leben eine mammut aufgabe
bei der die behörden aus ost und west
enger denn je zusammen arbeiten und
denkbar ohne die deutsche einheit
trotzdem mal weil sonst fehlt es ja die
die grundlage auch für für neues na also
diskussion brauchen wir trotzdem
also dann hat man kein fortschritt wenn
es alles nur nur einheitsbrei ist
die fahrt geht weiter zum höchsten punkt
des nationalparks den brocken
auf dem weg liegt dieses ehemalige hotel
gunter karste geht mit uns hinein
vor gut 30 jahren erzählt er logierten
hier verdiente mitarbeiter des ddr-
staatssicherheitsdienstes sie machten
urlaub von ihrer aufgabe das eigene volk
zu bespitzeln
in diesen räumen scheint die zeit stehen
geblieben zu sein
beim ehemaligen ddr-bürger kaste sorgt
sie noch heute für bittere erinnerungen
als student im sechsten semester hatte
ich also auch ein zusammentreffen mit
der staatssicherheit die wollte dass ich
mein studium vorhin bespitzelt und habe
das abgelehnt wohl wissen dass das für
mich hätte konsequenzen haben können
aber damit hält man gelebt dass wir uns
dazu auf sich der harz ist unser zuhause
das geht jetzt nicht dann ist das ziel
erreicht auf über 1.100 metern der
brocken 1 thermisch abgeregelt horchten
sowjets und der ddr-geheimdienst mit
diesen anlagen tief hinein in den westen
jetzt wächst und gedeiht gleich nebenan
der ganze stolz des botanikers kaarster
ein garten mit hunderten pflanzen
das heißt da brocken hat also ein
stückchen seine ursprünglichkeit der
natur nähe
im zuge der zeit in den letzten 30
jahren zurück erhalten und vor dem
mikrofon sind wir wirklich glücklich und
die aufgabe sagt gunter karste gehe
weiter so lange bis eines tages
endgültig wieder das zusammen gewachsen
ist was zusammengehört